l'étau se resserre encore au tour
d'andrew cuomo selon un rapport
d'enquêté indépendante publiée mardi le
gouverneur démocrate de l'état de new
york aurait harcelé sexuellement
plusieurs femmes andré comeau elle nie
les faits ont rejoint tout de suite
notre reporter à notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnet
bonjour thomas alors le gouverneur de
l'état de new york est au coeur d'un
scandale andrew cuomo le gouverneur
démocrate a répondu hier à une
conférence de presse accablantes de la
procureur de l'état malgré son démenti
sa position est quelque peu fragilisé et
président américains réclament sa
démission
oui andrew comeau c'est un gouverneur le
gouverneur de l'état de new york depuis
2011 il est donc démocrate il a une
influence au sein de ce parti et vous en
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler lors
de cette pandémie de kobe 19 puisqu'ils
s'étaient opposés à de nombreuses
reprises à la politique menée à l'époque
par le président donald trump il est
donc la cible d'accusations de
harcèlement sexuel onze femmes
témoignent contre lui et il ya eu donc
hier une conférence de presse de la part
de la procureur de l'état de new york
une conférence de presse que l'on pourra
qualifier à d'akab lente puisque donc
les détails de ce qu il est reproché à
andré comeau ont été dévoilés notamment
des baisers des étreintes non désirées
un environnement de travail toxiques au
total ce sont 165 pages d'investigation
qui ont été a dévoilé hier je propose
d'écouter un extrait justement de cette
conférence de presse
gilbert
tijerina notre enquête a révélé qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d' incident isolé et au
prince
ils s'inscrivaient dans un schéma
runners le comportement du gouverneur en
matière de harcèlement sexuel
nancy méritait pas aux membres de son
équipe lui c'est un peu aussi à d'autres
employés de l'état y compris à une
policière de l'état qui faisait partie
de sa garde rapprochée
state trooper cet entretien
alors vous pouvez l'imaginer ces
accusations ont fait l'effet d'une bombe
médiatique ici aux etats-unis et puis
quelques instants plus tard quelques
instants après cette conférence de
presse une allocution d'andrew comeau a
été diffusée sur la quasi totalité des
chaînes d'informations ici aux etats
unis un exercice de communication
savamment orchestrée ou le gouverneur de
new york elle rejette les accusations il
se définit comme quelqu'un de tactile
par nature il a d'ailleurs publié un
certain nombre de photos de lui au cours
de ces dernières années où on peut le
voir en train d'embrasser ou d'étreindre
un certain nombre de personnes comme
pour expliquer qu'il n'y avait
absolument aucune ambiguïté dans ses
gestes ecoutez-la donc là la locution
dansereau comeau qui a été diffusé hier
wright do better with pipe avec je
plaisante avec les gens je dis des
blagues certaines meilleurs que d'autres
je suis la même personne en public et en
privé
de stade
je comprends maintenant qu'il ya des
perspectives générationnel 1 culturel
qu'honnêtement je n'avais pas totalement
apprécié j'ai appris que cela
une allocution qui a remis une pièce
dans la machine transformant cette
affaire en un véritable feuilleton
politico médiatique faisant la une de
tous les médias aient compris de la
chaîne cnn une chaîne où officie le
frère d'andrew comeau il s'appelle chris
comeau il anime quotidiennement une
tranche d'information le soir donc sur
l'antenne de cnn et hier soir il n'a pas
dit un seul mot sur cette affaire qui
agite est pourtant évidemment la sphère
médiatique américaine il faut dire que
son frère donc chris comeau a aidé le
gouverneur de new york a préparé sa
stratégie pour répondre à ces
accusations de harcèlement sexuel elle a
évidemment vous pouvez l'imaginer la
pression est très forte autour du
gouverneur de new york pour qui l'idée
pour qu'il démissionne la question a
même été posée au président américain
joe biden hier suite à une conférence de
presse sur un tout autre sujet sur le
kobe de 19,1 journaliste interroge joe
biden écouter
est libre maintenant l'appeler à
démissionner étant donné que les
enquêteurs
témoignages des monstres était crédible
je m'en tiens à cette déclaration la
paix maintenant a démissionné
devrait être mis en examen est démis de
ses fonctions prenons une chose à la
fois je pense qu'il devrait démissionner
je comprends que le parlement de l'état
puisse décider de le poursuivre mais je
ne le sait pas avec certitude
je n'ai pas pris connaissance de toutes
les données
voilà donc l'étau qui se resserre autour
d' andrew comeau une position qui
devient de plus en plus difficilement
tenable pour lui surtout que danser une
déclaration ressurgissent de sa part
notamment un ancien tweet daté de 2013
où il a appelé à la tolérance zéro pour
toute personne coupable d'harcèlement
sexuel alors pour le moment andrew comme
on n'a toujours pas démissionné mais la
pression est très forte d'ailleurs il y
à une procédure de destitution qui a été
lancée dans l'état de new york notamment
sous l'impulsion des démocrates